WESLEY: Hi, and welcome to
"Serverless Migration Station."
I'm Wesley from Google,
joined by Martin
to help you modernize
your apps running
on one of our serverless
compute platforms.
In this and the next
few migration modules,
our little friend
Porter will take you
on a journey to migrate
from App Engine taskqueues
to Cloud Tasks.
That said, this video won't
feature any migrating at all.
MARTIN: Oh really, Wes?
Why not?
I thought this was the
"Serverless Migration" video
series.
What's up with that?
WESLEY: Aw.
You caught me, Martin.
Yeah, usually Porter does take
users from point A to point B.
But here in module 7, we
need to take a detour first
to reacquaint folks with
App Engine taskqueues.
We'll add their queues to the
module 1 Flask Engine NEB app.
Then we can migrate it to
Cloud Tasks ahead in module 8.
MARTIN: OK, I get it.
So we're going to take one of
our original Python 2 apps,
add App Engine taskqueues
to it, and then learn
how to migrate to Cloud Tasks?
WESLEY: Yep.
You got it, Martin.
In module 1, we migrated from
App Engine's webapp2 framework
to Flask, a popular framework
in the Python community.
While webapp2 apps
run on App Engine,
Flask apps run on App Engine
and most other hosting services.
So pause here to review
the module 1 video
and do its codelab to reacquaint
yourself with that migration,
because this module picks up
where that one leaves off.
MARTIN: Ah, yes.
I remember that migration.
So what are we going
to use taskqueues
for in our sample app, Wes?
WESLEY: Yeah.
Glad you asked, Martin.
Well, you know our app creates a
new entity for each page visit.
Because it only shows the
10 most recent visits,
there's no need to keep
all the old ones, right?
Why take up all the
extra space, and possibly
exceed our Datastore free
tier, and possibly have to pay?
Well, we'll have to add a task
that deletes all visits older
than the oldest one shown.
MARTIN: OK.
I have to be honest.
I haven't used App Engine
taskqueues in quite a while.
Can I get my hands
dirty and do it myself
while you're showing
us on screen?
WESLEY: Absolutely.
Go and grab your module 1
code if you did the codelab,
or clone the repo or download
the zip file if you didn't.
Pause here if you
need to do that.
Module 1 is where we'll start.
If you want to do
this by hand with me
now or on your own time, please
follow the module 7 codelab.
Ready?
Let's go to the computer
now and do this.
Since we're only adding the
use of taskqueues to our app,
there are no changes to
any of the config files.
Python 2 users should ensure
your lib folder is intact.
If not or you're
unsure, just delete it
and rerun the pip
install command.
Since it's always good to
start from a working app,
use gcloud app deploy to
redeploy the module 1 app
and ensure it works
before we update it.
This is one of the
few modules where
the app will look and work
slightly differently when
we're done.
To delete the oldest
entries, we'll
use some timestamp utilities,
like those in the time
and datetime modules.
We're also going to be
adding logging to help debug.
Most importantly, we need
to add the taskqueue API.
The imports are in the
best practice ordering
of standard library
packages first,
followed by
third-party libraries,
then finally local
libraries, and everything
in alphabetical order.
Since we only care about older
visits not shown to the user,
it has nothing to do with
when visits are created,
so store_visit stays the same.
The actual fetching
of most recent visits
hasn't changed, either.
But instead of returning
with the data right away,
let's use the timestamp
of the oldest visit
and delete everything
older than that.
We'll save a human-readable log
entry and save it for the user.
That's followed by the most
important part, creating
the push task to do
the work, passing
in the timestamp and the
handler the task should post to.
Once the task is
added, return the data
like before, but also include
the oldest visit timestamp.
When the task runs, the
taskqueue service sends an HTTP
POST to the handler trim(),
so let's move to that now.
Flask routes
default to HTTP GET,
but tasks are POSTed
to their handlers,
so that's why trim()'s decorator
is designated that way.
To start, it grabs the oldest
entity timestamp we got from
fetch_visits().
Next, it queries for all
entities older than that.
We don't need the data,
so just ask for keys only
to speed it up.
If old visits exist, log how
many we're deleting and do it.
Otherwise, log there aren't any.
And that's it for the task.
The main handler stores and
fetches visits as before,
but now we have a timestamp
for the oldest displayed visit
to let the user know
that visits older
than that will
automatically be deleted.
Both the data and
oldest visit timestamp
are sent to the
template for rendering.
But before we do that, we
better update that template.
The majority of the
template stays the same,
but check for a timestamp.
If so, show that older
visits will be deleted.
Because it checks for the
existence of the timestamp,
this template can be
used in other modules,
because there are
no side effects
if the timestamp isn't there.
And those are all the
changes necessary to add
push tasks to our existing app.
If you did everything correctly
and redeployed the sample app,
you should now see an
additional message down
at the bottom letting
users know what visits
were deleted by the push task.
OK, back to the program.
MARTIN: Thanks for
the tutorial, Wes.
Where should I go if I
want to reacquaint myself
with App Engine taskqueues?
WESLEY: Well,
Martin, I'd say start
with the taskqueue
overview page in the docs.
While our simple app
only uses push tasks,
you'll find docs for both
push and pull queues there.
MARTIN: Cool, I'll take a look.
But can you give me a heads-up
on what we're doing next?
WESLEY: Sure, Martin.
Now that we have App Engine
taskqueues in our app,
we'll migrate it to Cloud
Tasks ahead in module 8.
If you want to read
ahead, check out the links
to the migration page, as
well as the Cloud Tasks
documentation.
You can also do the
module 8 codelab
if you want to get
started on it right away,
or go back to the repo to
either look at the code
or check out the next video.
And we look forward to having
all of you join us for module 8
and moving to Cloud Tasks.
This is Wesley.
On behalf of Martin
and Porter, we
hope to see you at that
next "Migration Station"
or on another "Serverless
Expedition" soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]